I am ready to drink tonight.
Director Bong Joon-Ho sweeping the 92nd Academy Awards...
...and hilariously showing us all that he clearly knows how to celebrate.
The South Korean filmmaker walked away with 4 Academy Awards...
Bong Joon-ho!
...including Best Original Screenplay, Best International Feature Film, Best Director and Best Picture.
And the Oscar goes to "Parasite."
This is the first movie from South Korea to be nominated and to win the Oscar.
All our loving crew members and cast members are here with us today.
Please send a round of applause to the actors and crew members of "Parasite."
"Parasite."
After winning Best International Feature, I thought I was done for the day...
...and was ready to relax.
And Todd and Sam, great directors I admire.
If the Academy allows, I would like to get a Texas Chainsaw,...
...split the Oscar trophy into five and share it with all of you.
Thank you.
I will drink until next morning.